a lot of constitutional questions
regarding the 2020 election
i'm sorry if this if this video turns
off on youtube halfway through i don't
know i guess i couldn't help it
but i have to read the news this is
happening right now
17 states are joining with texas
to sue georgia michigan wisconsin and
pennsylvania
over their election irregularities what
states are they
alabama arkansas florida indiana kansas
louisiana mississippi missouri montana
nebraska north dakota
oklahoma south carolina south dakota
sweet old tennessee my new home state
utah and west virginia and
president trump by the way is signing on
here as a candidate
who believes his rights were infringed
by
election irregularities and we say
irregularities we're talking about a
whole
wide range of of activities
many of which were caught on camera so
you the big tech oligarchs can't
deny that they have they can deny that
they happened but it's preposterous
they're asking us to believe them over
our own lying eyes
and in the case of pennsylvania we're
talking about a flagrant violation
of the state constitution by permitting
the use of widespread mail-in ballots
ken paxton who's the attorney general in
texas
was explaining the premise behind this
lawsuit
it's really important to my state that
my voters be
represented and if other states don't
follow the constitution
and if their state legislature isn't
responsible for
overseeing their elections and we have
other people who are not under the
constitution
under the constitution supposed to be
doing this it affects my state and so
our job is to make sure that the
constitutions follow and that every vote
counts
and in this case i'm not sure that every
vote was counted not in the right way
it is the responsibility of state
legislatures per the constitution
to set the the rules for election of
electors and in this case
those were overridden in the four states
were talking about were overridden by
other
officials whether they were judges or
other governmental officials and that's
not the way our constitution works
and that's the challenge we have in
front of the court can this be
overridden by
people who are not responsible under the
constitution for doing this
i totally agree with everything that ken
paxton just said he's a very strong
attorney general by the way and
presumably has a good political career
ahead of him
totally agree with that i i also agree
with the point that was made by arthur
bloom today
arthur bloom is a conservative writer
and editor who pointed out the democrats
you know even in their name take
ownership of this word democracy
and they say that any attempts to to
change the
outcome of the certification is
undermining democracy
and if you go to the state legislatures
to override the unconstitutional
decisions
of say judges or of election officials
that that's somehow undermining
democracy because democracy is only what
democrats say is
give me a break give me a break
i'm not saying that this is an ideal way
to conduct an election i'm not saying
that this
wasn't a complete debacle i think this
election was a debacle because
of corrupt election officials and
because of misguided state legislatures
and because of partisan state supreme
courts
however going to the state legislatures
and allowing a constitutional process to
play out
and having them use their legal
authority to
process and execute a presidential
election
is not undemocratic compared to
having some electors pass some new or
having some election officials rather
pass some new regulations during a
presidential election to change the way
that people vote and then having that
vote be certified
the word democratic is much broader than
we're describing here
and frankly it's it's even sort of
secondary to the question of
the legal process established by the
constitution
all of that said i do not want to get
people's hopes up here
i said yesterday that the fat lady has
not sung
yet but you can hear her warming up you
can hear her in the far distance
clearing her throat going up and down
her scales
this lawsuit from texas is the last
stand it just is a matter of time there
isn't
time left the electors are going to vote
in a matter of days
so this is it even if there were some
magnificent other lawsuit that were
being prepared
that had heaping helpings of kraken in
it there isn't time for it anymore
and nobody's gonna care how explosive it
is i keep going back to the example
of lyndon johnson who stole a 1948
senate election
and we know it with certainty as of say
1990
but okay i guess that's a moral victory
for conservatives
meanwhile johnson had already
left the senate left the vice presidency
left the presidency and died okay
we got him we got him no
he already had his effect i don't have
any confidence in the supreme court that
they will
rule properly on this case and i don't
have any confidence in the supreme court
that they'll even take it up
i think the other day when they shot
down
the pennsylvania appeal which senator
cruz was going to argue before the court
some people are saying well they shot
that down because it would have been
redundant they were waiting for the
texas lawsuit i don't think so
i don't think so i think regardless of
what maybe they hear the case probably
they don't but
even if they do i just don't think
they're going to weigh
in on behalf of trump and on behalf of
people who feel that this election
was held in an irregular way which is
which is
incontrovertible no matter what no
matter what
youtube wants to say about it so this is
the stand i'm really pleased that texas
is doing this i'm very pleased
that my new state of tennessee is doing
this you know all my exes live in texas
which is why i hang my hat in tennessee
but both states doing great work as are
those other states that are signing on
and the trump campaign